[Música]
a escala en parís
braulio moro
bienvenidos a escala en parís una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con france24 en español la
pandemia del coronavirus ha llevado al
cierre de museos y zonas arqueológicas
alrededor del mundo en este sentido esta
pandemia ha causado graves problemas en
lo que se refiere a la conservación del
patrimonio cultural de la humanidad para
hablar del incremento del robo de piezas
arqueológicas y de bienes patrimoniales
alrededor del mundo saludamos aquí en
nuestro estudio a ernesto ottone
subdirector de cultura de la unesco la
organización de las naciones unidas para
la ciencia la educación y la cultura
ernesto tono bienvenido a esta escala en
parís muchas gracias ernesto el
patrimonio cultural de la humanidad se
ha convertido en una de las víctimas
colaterales de lakovic 19 como decíamos
en varios países y alrededor del mundo
se han cerrado museos fondas
arqueológicas y ustedes han detectado un
incremento del robo de piezas y de otros
bienes culturales que lo que ustedes han
remarcado notablemente en este año que
viene determinado
bueno este año 2020 que pasó hace unos
años más terrible para el mundo la
cultura en general pero sin duda para el
patrimonio afectado principalmente si
uno se imagina que de los 95 mil museo
en el mundo 95 mil museos el 93% los
museos tuvo que cerrar por periodo de
tres y algunos han estado se ha acabado
desde hace ocho meses los sitio
arqueológico han tenido menos seguridad
todo el tema de inventariado de la obra
no ha sido su curso normal y eso ha
significado que con los socios con los
que trabajábamos que son interpol que
son la organización mundial de la aduana
las cifras no indican que efectivamente
el aumento del tráfico ilícito a través
de distintas formas estamos hablando a
través de plataformas digitales pero
también de la venta en línea ha crecido
enormemente en este periodo desde marzo
en adelante por lo tanto estamos
preocupados en este terreno usted lo
dice hay las plataformas de en línea
notablemente sitios como por ejemplo
facebook como
como wow antich por una situación en
unos ejemplos que han sido señaladas
como responsables de analizar de
facilitar precisamente este tráfico de
piezas que han sido robadas que nos
puede decir a este propósito bueno la
verdad que en el mes de mayo tuvimos la
buena noticia que después de tres años
de trabajo con alguna esta plataforma
específicamente con facebook e instagram
ellos decidieron poner un banner es
decir prohibir o
perseguir cuando el tráfico se hacía a
través de su plataforma sin embargo hoy
en día muy difícil detectarlo porque
sobre todo de los artefactos que son
robados en sitio ecológico porque no
están inventariados por lo tanto uno no
sabe el destino o sea el origen y por lo
tanto es muy difícil hacer una
persecución antiguamente el tráfico
pasaba por aduanas y aduanas tenía un
control muy fuerte hoy en día aduana
reconoce que desde el año pasado ha
estado concentrado en temas de salud es
decir de las máquinas respiratorias
entonces tampoco también había un
poquito menos de cuidado en lo que
circulaba a través de esto pero la
verdad es que a través de la plataforma
cuando tú compras un objeto de arte y tú
no sabes el origen pero tú supone que un
origen legal tú tienes distintas formas
de hacer el envío entonces no solamente
la compra también es el envío si tú
declara un objeto como un juguete de
menos de 100 dólares no pasa la prisión
de agua la mente por lo tanto te llega a
la casa y eso es
algo que cuando se ama la convención de
1970 que hoy día se han desvanecido ya
para el país se han ratificado no
existían esos instrumentos y no existía
esa forma de pensar que podía haber un
tráfico lo claro es que hoy en día
tenemos que concentrarnos en el esfuerzo
no solamente las ventas presenciales que
se han disminuido porque han habido
menos sino la venta online y es la
preocupación que se nos viene para los
próximos años usted señor al
efectivamente bueno correcto facebook
ahí junto con instagram al final de
cuentas es el mismo dueño y la misma
empresa han puesto medidas para frenar
un poco esta situación antes de que esas
medidas fueron tomadas ustedes habían
detectado si no mal recuerdo más de 120
grupos hagamos de cuenta que este es un
gran árbol 120 grupos que hacen como una
especie de ramas y más de 500 mil
personas que podrían ser las hojas del
árbol que se dedican precisamente a
la circulación al tráfico de piezas de
bienes culturales como usted dice es
difícil control de esto que se puede
hacer frente a esa situación hoy en día
por lo menos para frenar en la medida de
lo posible este tráfico de bienes
culturales alrededor del mundo bueno
interprete a decir que es un crimen
organizado está hoy día detectado como
tal que tú me hablas de 120
intermediarios es porque hay algo que
está construido de ese modo y
cuando cuando se inventa esta convención
de 1970 que ratificado lo está un
miembro para el contra el tráfico
ilícito y la circulación de bienes
culturales de origen dudosa lo que se
intenta hacer es formar y capacitar a
los países para tener tema jurídico y
normativo que sea semejante entre ellos
cosa que en raya no se ha logrado por lo
tanto tú puedes tener una misma región
américa latina por ejemplo todos los
países tienen legislaciones distintas y
tienen penas distintas y tienen
controles distintas una las grandes
recomendaciones desde los años 70 ha
sido que en las policías
hay que formar cuerpos especializados
como lo tiene los países europeos italia
francia alemania son los grandes
ejemplos donde hay fuerzas que se
dedican a eso a poder hacer seguimiento
a poder controlar a estar en línea hoy
en día está lo que se llama la lista
roja de objetos robados que muchas veces
que es muy muy mala
mal material para poder exhibir son
objeto generalmente están en bodegas o
que están en el sitio arqueológico y que
todavía no hacían registrado en buena
calidad por lo tanto hoy en día lo que
nos pasa a nosotros es que los estados
miembro es decir los países nos piden
muchas veces intervenir en ventas de
acciones de opciones causas si para
poder detener una venta ya que ellos
consideran que ese objeto fue robado si
el país no tiene como comprobar que ese
objeto es el que se va a vender es muy
difícil parar esa venta el año pasado
logramos en un caso de guatemala una
pieza de méxico a quienes planteas es
precisamente seguimos también en
alemania pero hoy en día lo que se trata
de hacer cuando pasa esto es
generalmente una relación bilateral
cuando la parte bilateral no funciona y
nos damos cuenta que una organización
internacional ahí intervenimos nosotros
hoy en día lo que tenemos que reforzar
las capacidades nacionales y inter
regionales para asegurar porque lo que
está pasando a que si uno
ejemplo áfrica por ejemplo el continente
de los 54 países hay todavía 14 18
países que no han ratificado la
convención por lo tanto lo que hacen
y son los que más reclaman por otros
temas también que tienen que la
restitución y tema más histórico pero
por ejemplo si esos países nos ratifican
el crimen organizado lo que busca es
pasar a través de esos países
evidentemente entonces si tú no tienes
de los 293 estaba un miembro que se
comprometen a tratar de avanzar en sus
legislaciones y tener normas comunes de
control está estas personas que se
llegan a esto van a buscar los medios y
los destinos y la circulación donde no
hay legislación que sea la correcta para
poder prevenir y frenar este tipo de
tráfico es hacer unas grandes
modificaciones que va a revelar al
convenio de 1970 más que una
modificación
una vez pero también hay que aplicarlo
si no lo aplica hay muchos países que
ratificaron pero que hoy en día no está
en sus prioridades hacen la aplicación
de las normativas pero esto en este
sentido se sabe
evidentemente el robo el tráfico de
bienes culturales empezó antes de la
pandemia claro está en 2011 a partir de
las revoluciones árabes y en países en
guerra como siria yemen irak irak etc se
han producido grandes robos pero la
situación ahora cubre a todos los países
ustedes han denunciado por ejemplo el
año pasado un caso de un robo de un van
gogh en holanda usted mismo denunció que
hace el año pasado nada menos que
algunos kilómetros en parís mismo no
traerán la famosa catedral de notre-dame
estoy un a punto de robarse piedras de
la catedral como hacen ustedes para
detectar esta situación porque son los
mecanismos de los que ustedes disponen
en casos como estos uno para frenarlo y
dos para castigar a los responsables
sabiendo ustedes lo que se me dice son
redes internacionales
el tema el freno yo le diría que el
único medio que tenemos día la
coordinación de toda la agencia que
tiene algo que ver es decir hoy en día
nosotros tenemos reuniones bimensuales
con interpol con la organización mundial
de aduanas con y con el council de
museos y con ellos estamos de algún modo
monitoreando lo que está pasando en la
relación con la estado miembro es
fundamental eso es para la prevención la
segunda parte es la formación es decir
como tú creas conciencia que lo que
estamos haciendo con la campaña que se
lanzó el año pasado y que va a seguir
todo este año de que este tráfico no es
algo ajeno es decir cuando hablamos este
tráfico termina en el living de tu casa
y tú no sabes el origen porque la
persona que te lo vende te está diciendo
que el legal claro el tema es que
nosotros que tenemos que concientizar es
que las personas que compra este objeto
está inconsciente de tener toda la
información de obtenerlo y el año pasado
nos encontramos con una campaña muy
fuerte de algunas casas de remate que
hice una gran campaña de nuestra campaña
nosotros no estamos criticando las casas
rematen y los museos que te arman sus
colecciones lo que queremos es asegurar
que lo que se muestre se exhibe o se
venda sea en condiciones legales y eso
lo que estamos discutiendo y por lo
tanto el segundo camino es la formación
en la formación del gran público y de
los especialistas también y lo tercero
el tema legislativo si tú no avanzas en
ese tema que un monte encia antes es muy
difícil frenar el tráfico ilícito piensa
que hace diez años ya se decía que el
tráfico de objetos de arte era el tercer
tráfico que producía más ganancias
después de la droga y las armas que si
no le decimos nosotros lo hiciste por
por lo tanto hoy en día estamos hablando
y sabemos muy bien como tú lo decía en
la región en la región árabe donde había
un movimiento extremista se financia en
gran parte para la compra de armas a
través del tráfico ilícito de oradea
pero hay una estimación en términos de
lo que representa en monto en volumen de
piezas robado sabiendo que está listo es
muy difícil hacer una estimación pero
tienen alguna mínima idea de contar la
última cifra que teníamos
además de el último día año de más de 13
mil objetos circulando ilegalmente esto
sin contar toda la base de datos de
objetos robados anteriores al baño 92 o
sea estamos hablando la última cifra
eran 12 mil objetos que andan circulando
por el mundo y que se tiene registro
hace poco la universidad de en alemania
una universidad no me acuerdo hacer acá
a su vez hizo un caso de estudio para
ver objetos de sirias que habían sido
robado por donde habían circulado hayan
circulado por 18 países distintos y se
hayan vendido 9 es el mismo objeto
entonces es cuestión de la evolución de
los padres
absolutamente y cada vez cambiando el
origen es decir antes se decía que salía
de esta región y de esta época iba
cambiando el objeto en el mismo no era
reproducción de veces entonces es un
tema muy complejo y tú lo dijiste es muy
difícil
aseverar por eso nosotros creemos que
por ejemplo el tema en los museos de lo
inventariado y de tener un sistema común
digital es lo que nos puede permitir eso
pues nos dan tiempo agradecemos a
ernesto ottone subdirector de cultura de
la unesco su presencia en estos estudios
muchísimas gracias a ustedes les damos
una nueva cita aquí la próxima semana en
otra escala en país
[Música]